alors il ya en fait deux scénarios qui
sont étudiées en premier scénario qui se
baserait en 2050 2060 sur une énergie
électrique il serait entièrement
renouvelable s'est produite entièrement
par des moyens dits non conventionnels
l'éolien le photovoltaïque le solaire et
c'est bon c'est le scénario le plus cher
pourquoi pas parce qu'il va falloir
beaucoup d'argent pour développer ce
type de
technologie c'est aussi un scénario qui
est assez risqué parce que pour
l'instant une partie de ces technologies
reste des producteurs intermittents
d'énergie un corps qui a pas de vent il
n'y a pas d'électricité dans les
éoliennes et le solaire c'est bien beau
mais la nuit ça produit pas d'énergie
bon donc là il ya un vrai problème
tout d'abord jacques qui est à blâmer
pour le semi échec de la coop 26 à
glasgow est ce que ces landes où la
chine comme on l'a entendu alors il ya
quand même beaucoup d'hypocrisie dans
toutes ces histoires parce que si on
regarde les volumes des émissions par
habitant de ces deux pays ils sont très
faibles l'un d'eux doit être autour de 1
8 tonne par habitant la chine autour de
7 tonnes et demi alors que les états
unis sont assez stone le canada à 17 le
japon à 13 donc on voit ya quand même
une très très grande différence on voit
où sont véritablement les pollueurs par
ailleurs il ya un point qui est
intéressant c'est la place relativement
basse de la france mais ça on va en
reparler scellier effectivement au
nucléaire après il est vrai aussi que le
fait qu'il n'y ait pas eu d'engagement
ferme sur les stratégies des uns et des
autres oui c'est un vrai problème est là
effectivement les indiens et chinois
n'ont pas voulu s'engager je dois
ajouter quand même que cette hypocrisie
elle ne concerne pas simplement l'inde
et la chine il ya aussi une hypocrisie
au sein de l'union européenne parce que
un certain nombre de pays se refuse à
classer l'énergie nucléaire parmi les
énergies décarbonées pour autant ils
sont bien contents d'acheter de
l'électricité produite par
l'énergie nucléaire à condition que
cette énergie que cette électricité ne
soit pas produit chez eux comme nos amis
allemands par exemple elle a fort bien
fixer les choses qui dans le monde
aimait le plus de co2 alors ça dépend
comment on va le calcul et si on
commence par calculé ça je dirais par
habitant alors voilà c'est tout à fait
évident vous voyez des pays en
développement comme l'inde le brésil
sont très très très bas c'est normal
c'est un niveau de développement qui est
aussi extrêmement fun la chine en dépit
du fait qu'elle soit maintenant la
première économie en parité de pouvoir
d'achat reste relativement faible
7 5 tonnes par habitant est évidemment
ce sont des pays comme les etats unis le
canada qui sont de gros émetteurs et on
voit là justement ça c'est un point
intéressant que la france est d'abord
faible sensiblement sous la moyenne de
l'union européenne hélas comme je vous
l'avais dit c'est évidemment le résultat
du fait qu' une partie de notre énergie
est produit par l'énergie nucléaire
alors après si on regarde les émissions
en volume global alors là ça change
effectivement la chine l'inde devient le
premier pollueur mondial mais c'est tout
simplement le fait de sa population sait
pas quelle elle les met beaucoup de co2
par habitant mais c'est la population on
est à plus d'un milliard 4 on voit quand
même que les etats-unis se retrouvent à
la moitié des émissions chinoises alors
qu ils sont cinq fois moins nombreux
donc ça veut bien dire qu'il y a un
problème dans le niveau d'émission des
états unis alors jacques quelle est la
situation en france alors en france si
vous voulez si on regarde à l'horizon
2050 ou à l'horizon 2060 qui l'horizon
qui est retenue ben on voit que les
émissions de co2 sont quand même très
lié à notre production d'énergie et
notre production d'énergie et il ya un
état 43 44 % assurée par le nucléaire
par l'électricité nucléaire si on y
rajoute les renouvelables alors dans les
renouvelables via touya l'éolien il ya
le soleil il ya surtout l'hydraulique
soul electro électricité bon
on arrive à 53 54 % la part du charbon
pourquoi nous savons être un pro non
parce que le charbon est un très gros
polluants c'est un très gros émetteur de
co2 bien la part du charbon elle est
très faible c'est au tour de 3,8 pour
cent par contre il ya bien une part
importante de plus de 40% qui est lié au
pétrole et au gaz et là c'est
essentiellement la question des
transports et la question aussi de la
production d'énergie primaire telle est
la question est donc comment faire pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone alors
pour atteindre cette neutralité carbone
justement si on se projette un horizon
2050 qui est l'horizon qui normalement
est retenue pour arriver à la neutralité
carbone bah on voit des choses qui
soient intéressantes
là on a le scénario de référence qui a
été calculé par le réseau de transport
d'électricité rte dans un rapport récent
et on voit qu'il y a des grandes
économies qui seront faites sur le
logement le logement si vous voulez
c'est le secteur en bleu qui est tout à
fait en bas du graphique on voit que
l'industrie elle continue qui étend en
orange
nous rend un peu rouge
eh bien on voit que l'industrie elle
continue à accroître sa consommation et
c'est assez normal parce que ce scénario
prend en compte la réindustrialisation
moins partielle de la france et puis on
voit quelque chose qui est très
intéressant c'est la part des transports
qui est en orange plus claires et des
envois que les transports
actuellement sont relativement faible
mais que si on bascule essentiellement
vers une consommation d'énergie c'est
une consommation d'énergie électrique
l'électrification des voitures
l'électrification des autobus et bien ça
va augmenter donc fondamentalement si on
veut vraiment aller vers gérer cette
neutralité carbone eh bien il va falloir
que l'on accroît notre production
d'électricité
mais la question c'est comment on va
t-on à produire alors ya en fait deux
scénarios qui sont étudiées mon premier
scénario qui se baserait en 2050 2060
sur une énergie électrique qui serait
entièrement renouvelable s'est produite
entièrement par des moyens dit on
conventionnelle l'éolien le
photovoltaïque le solaire et c'est bon
c'est le scénario le plus cher pourquoi
parce qu'il va falloir beaucoup d'argent
pour développer ce type de
technologie c'est aussi un scénario qui
est assez risqué parce que pour
l'instant une partie de ces technologies
reste des producteurs intermittents
d'énergie quand ce n'est pas demain il
n'y a pas d'électricité dans les
éoliennes et le solaire c'est bien beau
mais la nuit ça produit pas d'énergie
bon donc là il ya un vrai problème et
puis il ya un autre scénario qui est
basé plutôt sur un mélange de entre les
énergies renouvelables et l'énergie
nucléaire ce scénario est nettement
moins cher puisqu'on passe de environ
1100 milliards pour le premier scénario
à autour de 800 milliards pour le
deuxième mais là il va falloir
évidemment reconstruire de nouvelles
centrales parce que il ya une partie des
centrales qui ont été construites dans
les années 75 à 85 90 qui sont
maintenant vieille et qui arrivent en
fin de vie opérationnelle et à quel coût
justement alors voilà ça c'est la
question est est l'une des erreurs que
l'on commet fréquemment c'est de
considérer que seul le coût de
production de l'énergie va être pris en
compte non alors il ya donc cette
production d'énergie avec ces deux
scénarios 1100 milliards pour le
renouvelable total un mélange
renouvelables et nucléaire autour de 770
à 800 milliards mais il ya aussi la
nécessité de faire d'énormes économies
d'énergie dans le logement
cela coûterait à l'horizon 2050
1200 milliards et puis après il faut
pommier si on veut avoir des voitures
électriques mais il faut construire des
infractions que ce soit des voitures
électriques ou des voitures à hydrogène
mais il va falloir construire des
infrastructures d'approvisionnement sur
les autoroutes sur les routes sans
encore ça coûte une somme importante
autour de 240 milliards au total on est
autour d'une dépense supplémentaire
de l'ordre de 60 milliards d'euros par
an hors inflation évidemment par la
toujours en euros constants donc de 60
milliards par an d'ici 2050 2060 alors
pensez vous justement à la lumière de
tous ces éléments que le gouvernement
choisisse sa stratégie oui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il y à une nette
inflexion inverse une relance du secteur
nucléaire on l'a entendu
emmanuel macron l'a dit lors de son
allocution du 9 novembre dernier donc là
où il est clair on va retourner d'une
certaine heure le nucléaire est ce que
maintenant on a bien pris la mesure de
ce qu'il va falloir faire en terme
d'investissement là par contre j'ai un
certain doute pourquoi pas ce que ça
veut dire qu'il faudra que l'on augmente
de 3 points la part des investissements
dans le pib nous sommes aujourd'hui à
23% il faudrait qu'on monte autour de 26
voire 27% certaines années alors oui
c'est possible mais pas avec les
méthodes actuelles de financement de
l'investissement il faudra probablement
revenir aux méthodes que nous utilisions
dans les années 60 et dans les années 70
est-ce que c'est compatible avec l'union
européenne car c'est ça aussi un
véritable problème alors en l'état non
mais on peut aussi penser que d'une
certaine manière les règles européennes
pourraient bouger elle pourrait changer
dans les années qui viennent et ça ça
sera l'un des grands débats et c'est un
débat qu'il faut même avoir tout de
suite en france il faut que les
différents candidats s'engagent à
demander même a exigé à l'union
européenne de changer ses règles de
financement car si cela n'est pas fait
eh bien on voit très bien que on
n'arrivera pas à faire la transition
écologique et la transition énergétique
dans les règles actuelles de l'union
européenne et ça ça pourrait vouloir
dire la mort de l'union européenne à
terre